Say that we’re given JUST this point here.
It’s pretty weird, but if you have a function
that tells you how far away the nearest surface
is, without telling you anything else, AT
ALL.
That’s actually all that’s needed to build
entire, complex 3d worlds, entirely out of
math.
The technique is called ray marching, and
it relies entirely on having a signed distance
function of the scene.
And signed distance functions aren’t too
hard to understand.
If i have a 2 points here, lets just make
some points appear, and we want the distance
between them, the distance is defined by the
length of p2 minus p1.
So NOWWWW if this were the distance between
say, a point and a circle instead.
We can model this with length p2 minus p1
- r, which you might realise gives you positive
values outside the circle, and negative values
inside, hence the signed part of the name.
So lets take our world and visualise it as
a distance field.
So for any given point in the world here,
we can use our magic signed distance function
and that will tell us how far away the nearest
surface is.
Now it doesn't tell us anything about where
it is, but weirdly enough, that doesn't actually
matter
To render this distance field, you need to
walk through it.
So if we’ve got our eye up here, let’s
say we want to get the pixel colour in this
direction.
So we know from the distance field function
that the closest surface is THIS far away.
Now we don't actually know where it is, but
that doesnt matter, we know we can travel
at least that distance safely along our view
vector.
Then you do the same thing at the new point,
you sample the distance function, figure out
how far things are, that gives you a safe
distance to travel, and then you can repeat
that process over and over again, until you’re
close enough to an object.
Extending this to 3d is pretty much exactly
the same thing, and that’s where you can
really start to do weird and cool stuff, things
that are super hard to do with normal techniques.
Nut before we do that, let's take a step back.
The scene ideally looks like this, but in
reality looks more like this.
Because we haven’t got any lighting.
We can assign colour based on depth, which
is basically distance fog, and that’ll give
us a start, but to light, we need normals.
Now normals are actually quite simple to generate
off of distance fields.
At the surface point, you take a couple extra
samples of the distance field near the point,
compute the differences along each axis, and
you’ve got a normal, it's really that simple.
Having normals gives you basic lighting.
To get shadows, you simply raymarch towards
any lights, recording how close you got to
any surfaces.
The awesome thing here being that you get
soft shadows for almost nothing.
So now that we know how to light, let's look
at how scenes are constructed.
You’ve got your basic spheres like we’ve
seen already, but you’ve also got other
stuff.
Some very smart people have already figured
out distance functions for a lot of common
shapes, cubes, donuts, pyramids, and even
have weird and exotic shapes.
You might be thinking, this is a lot of work
to do really basic stuff.
And that's sort of true actually.
But this is where it starts to get interesting,
because you can combine and distort things
in ways you just CAN'T with traditional techniques.
So we have functions for individual shapes,
but what’s not immediately obvious is that
having multiple shapes is as simple as taking
a min of their SDF values.
So in this case having a box and sphere is
as simple as min of the sphere’s SDF value
and the box’s SDF value.
And because combining objects is just a min,
an interesting property of the min of 2 functions
is that it can be blended together, it can
be smoothed out.
Look at these 2 functions here, I’ve got
just a basic line and a parabola.
Now if i were to take the min of these 2 functions,
it would look something like this, so we’ve
got the min of these 2 functions.
But right where the functions meet, you’ve
got this sharp edge, and ideally we want them
to smoothly meet instead, kinda blend just
between.
And luckily this is a solved problem already,
smooth maximums exist.
So a smooth min is just -smoothmax(-a, -b,
k), for some k smoothing value.
So with our 3d objects, I can slowly adjust
the smoothing coefficient here and we got
one just kinda melting into the other like
its’ made of butter or something.
From here it just gets wilder, because now
you can start really messing with these distance
fields.
So combining objects is called a union, which
is one operation in constructive solid geometry,
or CSG.
The opposite of a union being a subtraction,
that’s when you subtract one object from
another, and with sdf’s, this is is a simple
max(-a, b)
The last operation being an intersection,
which is forming an object only where 2 objects
meet, and again, super easy, that’s a max(a,
b);
Operations to transform objects actually modify
the space itself, so we can take our combined
object, and apply rotations, scales, pretty
similarly to the way you’d expect to do
it for normal 3d objects.
But more exotic transformations like bends
and twists are possible as well, which I mean
yeah you could do that in a vertex shader,
so lets see some stuff that isn’t possible
in a vertex shader.
Since you’re actually transforming the space
itself, I can do weirder stuff like repeat
the space, creating multiple copies of the
same object, and this is pretty much for free
in the shader.
This doesn't stop me from applying any individual
transforms, rotations, or basically do whatever
I want to each copy either
And we can do this pretty much in any direction,
all the way to infinite, which is pretty neat.
And you may be surprised to know, but pretty
much this entire video was made using shaders,
raymarching, and signed distance functions.
So they’re a pretty versatile and fun thing
to know a bit about.
If you’ve wanted to up your shader game,
check out my GLSL course.
I cover a lot of the basic concepts in much
more detail, otherwise, the code will be up
on github.
Until next time, cheers.